[Music]
4.9% of our universe is made up of
ordinary stuff the stuff that you and I
and the earth and the moon and the Sun
everything we can see in the universe
that accounts for just four point nine
percent so you might be feeling very
small and insignificant in the universe
just one person on planet Earth which is
just one star and a galaxy many many
galaxies that make you feel
insignificant but take it away from this
point now actually you are truly special
because you are made up of the stuff in
our universe that's really really small
and unique so we're all very special you
can take that away um but if you ask a
physicist what they understand electrons
protons quarks all of these lovely words
that you know that's just for point nine
percent of the universe and the rest of
our universe is dark now we've got
twenty six point eight percent of our
universe is made up of something we call
dark matter it's the strong
gravitational force in our universe that
glues our own Milky Way galaxy together
if you didn't have dark matter
our own Milky Way galaxy would simply
fly apart I want to focus on this stuff
that we've called dark energy 68.3% of
our universe made up of something called
dark energy this is just the name that
we've given to some mysterious source of
energy that's making our universe expand
faster and faster each and every day
this is very strange idea but you know
something is causing our University of
spanned faster and faster it's like
energies coming out of nothing so I can
par the list of all of the different
things that it could be and top on the
list to explain this very strange
observation requires us to think about
the physics of nothingness it's a bit of
a strange thing to think about now there
are big regions of our universe where
there's absolutely nothing nothing at
all there's no particles like we're made
up of this no dark matter expansive
nothingness nothing apart from virtual
particles that can simply pop in and out
of existence and in doing so they give
the universe energy and this is not
complete science fiction this has
actually been measured in laboratory you
can create a vacuum inside a laboratory
and you can measure these virtual
particles that can pop in and out of
existence it's something that comes
directly from quantum theory and is well
known about and what happens in our
universe if you've got an expanding
universe we have more and more
nothingness because the universe is
getting bigger and bigger if there's
more nothingness there's more chance
these virtual particles to pop into
existence giving us energy which causes
the universe to expand even faster and
we get this wonderful perpetual motion
machine and it's a glorious theory and
could that be the answer to the
challenge I was set unfortunately not
because if you take the measurements
that they've made in laboratory of what
happens in that in in the lab or if you
take the theories of particle physics
our universe shouldn't exist as it does
today if the physics of nothingness as
we understand it was right our universe
should have accelerated out to a
gigantic scale long before the first
stars and galaxies ever formed so we can
tick that one off the list maybe um so
I'm going to list here of all the
different ideas of what's causing the
expansion of our universe to get faster
and faster each and every day top of the
list is this idea of nothingness the
energy of a vacuum it could just be the
particle physics got their sums wrong it
happens all the time
all the time they can't trust particle
physicists no you can maybe but
sometimes they do get things wrong
that's top of the list that's what most
scientists think at the moment to
explain this mysterious dark side of our
universe number two on the list maybe
there's a new weird force field in the
universe there are four fundamental
forces that we know about four
fundamental forces gravity keeps you
stuck on the ground electromagnetism
keeps your particles stuck together the
strong and weak nuclear force and those
are forces that act on really really
small scales
those are our 440
maybe there's a thief that we don't know
about one idea that's out there number
three maybe Einstein's theory of gravity
is wrong so everything that I've talked
about so far is all within a framework
that Einstein got it rights number four
the topic of our discussion today the
multiverse and that may be the answer to
this whole puzzle of why we've got this
weird universe that's accelerating
really rapidly maybe that's just because
we live in a really weird universe in a
sea of multiple universes and maybe that
can explain all of these weird
observations it could be that the
particle physicists have got it right
this energy is just coming from the
vacuum but we just happen to be in a
really weird universe where the vacuum
behaves differently than we'd expect so
that's the subject of our of our talk
today thinking about the multiverse now
and whenever you talk about the
multiverse in scientific circles people
start kind of like making that sort of
noise stop getting anxious to start
rubbing their hands now and as
scientists our job is people come up
with theories scientists will come up
with a theory we build some equipments
and design and experiment we go out and
test the theory and our goal is to prove
the theory wrong and that's kind of the
way that science works and the problem
with this idea of the multiverse theory
that a lot of scientists get really
anxious about is that it's impossible to
design an experiment to directly test
this idea of the multiverse because by
definition these are the universes if
they exist are outside of our universe
and there's no way we can communicate
with them if nothing can travel faster
than the speed of light so and we've
already decided that Einstein's theories
may be right so at least we take that
off higher up in the list so it's very
hard to communicate with these other
universes and so some scientists will
say this is a pointless theory to even
consider because I cannot test it is
untestable and therefore we're not even
going to consider it but what I want to
share with you
day is three different ways that we can
actually test this idea of of the
multiverse and we can't directly go out
and observe these other universes but we
can make observations in our own
universe that can tell us about what
else might be out there in the
multiverse so let's start off with a
definition of what is our universe so if
we're going to embrace Einstein's theory
of general relativity then nothing can
travel faster than the speed of light
and so our universe what we can observe
is limited by how far light could have
traveled since the Big Bang which was
13.8 billion years ago so what I'm gonna
describe as our universe is a sphere
around us which is the size of how long
it would take light to travel 13.8
billion years and that is going to be
our definition of our universe and I can
do lots of experiments within our
universe because I can make all of these
different observations umm now one
experiment I can make is I can ask does
our universe look like it's infinite now
let's take ourselves back to to the days
when people weren't sure whether the
earth was flat or not and actually there
seems to be a rebirth movement of the
whole the earth is flat thing like all
of my undergraduates at one one week all
decided that the earth was flat and I
had to show them a load of images that
it wasn't the earth it's not flat but
imagine that you didn't know that
imagine that you were inside a football
stadium this is the hips football
stadium up in Edinburgh best football
team by the way I know we're down in
England but this is the best Scottish
team anyway
imagine you were in the football stadium
and you were trying to work out whether
the earth was flat based on your
evidence within that stadium you can't
see outside of the of the arena you
would say that the earth was flat let's
now move ourselves to the Netherlands
another very flat place at excellent
some of the mounts are down here at the
front and again as far as you look you
would say that the earth was flat yeah
so as far as you look the definition of
something is flat as if I set off in one
direction I won't come back on myself
and of course when people did go and
navigate the earth they found that
indeed if they set up in one direction
eventually they would come back in on
themselves but I can make this same
measurement in our universe what I can
observe in our universe and I can say
how flat is our universe if I set off in
one direction well I keep on going
forever
now I've made this measurements lots of
other people have made these
measurements and I can tell you based on
how flat our own universe is I can tell
you that the rest of the universe has to
be has to have enough has to be big
enough to contain at least a hundred
other universes the same size of our own
just because I know how flat our own
universe is and that tells me how flat
the rest of the universe out there must
be so I know that our own universe there
has to be at least a hundred other ones
out there like our own and that's our
first piece of it and I don't think
anyone can object to that one cuz those
are really detailed measurements that
we've made for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you